Speaker 1: So this is the expected result. Of what
is happening nationally with abortion rights and
with Roe v Wade. We talked about last week how
this was a concern. This was something that was
expected to happen and now it is happening. Texas
hospitals are refusing to see people with serious
pregnancy issues for fear of violating post Roe
abortion ban, according to a medical group. We
talked about it ten days ago. And much like with
other things people wrote in saying, David, that's
hypothetical. David, that's theoretical. Well,
it's now reportedly happening. Check this out.
The Texas Medical Association says some
hospitals are refusing emergency care for
pregnancy complications. They fear violating the
near-total abortion ban in Texas. The group said
a woman was refused treatment for her ectopic
pregnancy until it eventually ruptured. This
is part of the Dallas Morning News. In a letter to
the Texas Medical Board seen by the newspaper, the
association said it received numerous complaints
that hospitals were blocking doctors from giving
pregnant people medically necessary care, which
includes ending a pregnancy. Remember that when
I first reported on this, some of the responses
were, David, that's not going to happen because
there are exceptions in these bills. And as I
pointed out, the medical exceptions in the Texas
abortion bill really are up to the discretion
of the doctor and can easily lead to gray area
scenarios where the doctors are afraid of being
second guessed not only by lawyers, by by but by
politicians sued for the actions that they decide
to take. And even if it would apparently be legal,
and even if you fought it and defend yourself
and got a lawyer and ultimately prevail,
what doctor wants to deal with that, even if you
believe you will ultimately come up on the right
side of the law? Do you really want to be dealing
with that for years? Because that's how long a
lot of these things will take. So the exceptions
explanation is bogus. The article goes on to say,
According to the paper, the letter described
one case of a woman who had an ectopic pregnancy
which allows the pregnancy that grows in the
fallopian tubes will never be viable but will
be life threatening. She was said to have
been refused treatment until her pregnancy
ruptured. When you delay or prevent care in that
scenario, it creates a substantial risk for the
patient's future reproductive ability and poses a
serious risk to the patient's immediate physical
well-being. Understand that with this condition. A
doctors know this is not going to ultimately lead
to a live human. I don't even know the words
to you. It's just not. And the correct thing
in these situations is to assist in terminating
the pregnancy. If you don't. Not only can you
put the pregnant woman at health risk, you can
also jeopardize her ability to even have future
healthy babies. And doctors are saying, even
though that's the case, the risk to me legally
feels so great that we may and in this case
did refuse treatment. The forced birth people
keep emailing me saying, Oh, you're fearmongering
about that. You're fearmongering about that.
And of course, it's now happening exactly as
predicted. And by the way, you know, for all
of the claims that they are pro-life. When the
mother dies, if it's before the fetus is viable,
the fetus dies, too. Not exactly pro-life to say
two deaths. Instead of what they believe to be
one. And when you think about what's happening in
Texas, it doesn't really sound like a developed
country. I mean, zoom out. I tweeted about this.
If I told you there is a place on this planet,
it has a notably higher infant mortality rate than
much of the developed world. Talking about Texas,
doctors are afraid of treating women with
pregnancy complications because there's crazy
anti-abortion laws inspired by the religion of
the people passing them, which makes the doctors
worried they'll get arrested for providing care.
Talking about Texas. And also, they're working
in facilities in hospitals whose power might go
out because they are dependent on generators,
in some cases because they've got this isolated
power grid without redundancy. Now they have
that by choice, not by necessity. There are
lots of parts of the world where what I just
described is not by choice. Most people would
not assume that that's the state of Texas. When
I give you those three things higher than than
most of the developed world, infant mortality
of doctors fearing, giving people the medical
treatment they need for fear of arrest and worries
about the power going out because of an isolated
power grid. I don't know what most people would
think, but most people would not think that it's a
state in the United States. That's what's going on
in Texas. And it's completely predictable. And it
wasn't just us predicting it. It's now happening